what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here we're gonna watch the trailer today
for a 24s hereditary a new drama horror
mystery film maybe she and hereditarily
inherited eating something that's had
great use for shout out today for any
[Music]
it's heartening to see so many streamers
you know faces here today I know my mom
would be very touched my mother was a
very secretive and pregnant woman
Oh split baby food money because she
need to defeat you she was a very
difficult woman put maybe explaining
[Music]
[Music]
at the end the guy from DiMaggio
Wow
I was not expecting to be like any of
that
from the very beginning there's a unique
way this movie is being shot I love that
opening shot into the dollhouse and
there's real people yeah wonder what the
dollhouse really represents because
she's building it it represents life and
then just the trailers give me crazier
crazyer going it looks like a
psychological deterioration one of my
favorite things with its executor right
at horror movies Toni Collette is great
in this genre yeah generally that one
pullquote about you know horror movie
about the things we inherit from our
parents is like that's the kind of
horror that I often appreciate the most
of the stuff that uses a metaphor for
its horrific elements yeah and you know
it's kind of horrifying the just the
inner workings of your mind and the
things that you would Herot that you
don't have control over that you didn't
know were there that you pick up over
time like that's a perfect ground to
draw horror out of and I love that
they're going there
reminds me of stuff like the babadook or
goodnight mom those things that draw
from personal terror
yes exactly seneschal terror and it's
like all projections from the internal
that looks incredibly unsettling I don't
think there's another horror movie
trailer that I've seen for 2018 that I
want to see more than this movie no this
one grabbed me for two straight minutes
character matches looking also
restrained and kind of simmering yeah
they had all these quotes plastered on
it I am praying to God this isn't like a
mother situation or because even though
mother was like one of my favorite
movies of last year I'll admit it was so
miss marketed
and this trailer has that like that
should and crazy title those quotes on
it that makes you go would be a
terrifying movie yeah yeah but this
looks like it'll probably be well done
they said from the people that split
into which two movies I greatly
appreciated this is a twenty four
they're willing to go all out with their
freakiness so knowing the production
company seems it's rather a family
horror drama it's great horror tale
about the demons we inherit more you
really say that looks that looks awesome
that looks that looks really awesome
performances are great that looks
awesome this guy transitioning from
Jumanji to this good man you went from
My Big Fat Greek Wedding to - did you
much do this I always know it's because
of the mole you do you Alex wolf and
Toni Collette man it's a guy's
directorial debut to like feature film
territorially beautiful well guys Angie
Terpening it's your page from the day
shout-out wanted to give you a shout out
today on this video because Andrew you
scare the [ __ ] out of me buddy you are
tall imposing ridiculously good-looking
already there I'm already intimidated
you are super smart like nobody's
business you can sing and also you have
been pressuring me to read ready player
one and the only reason I wanna read it
is because I'm terrified of you right
now I'm afraid you're gonna come over
here rip off my head reach down my neck
and pull out my spine and that's just
your natural strength that's even from
you not even going to the gym yeah so I
might read ready player one out of fear
it's gonna be a terrifying experience
reading the book and an anxious one and
a lot of rereading the lines I'm so
caught up in my own thoughts and I'm
like oh crap I pray that I read the
whole page not knowing what I read I
gotta really understand this for me when
I report back to and read it I really
read it just like even my opinion on the
book but and I know right now you're
also going through a minorly tough time
and I want you to know buddy that John's
here for you I am call me anytime buddy
semi so does send me somewhat of he
sends mark time photos hahaha hey you
knew it you knew it hard turn
anyway guys you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
about and also download a false and
start us at people patreon we have
full-length TV show music video
reactions a weekly Q&A is catch you on
the flippety-flip Q's a name